so now I'm going to put the fourth wall
and talk to you about the blog in a
macro of why you guys should be doing it
[Music]
shorting today in London we're even
talking like Oh what is what's the vlog
gonna be today unless we you know we all
feel about it best believe it we ain't
gonna let the chitlin because what were
made for you gotta take your chance
whenever you get the opportunity to let
everyone needs memories you get
understand that she was steps and what
you see is what you get so you've got to
get it get you to talk to me don't need
to worry about it everybody the path you
chose thank you where you wanna call
what you gotta go get it if you want to
be crazy way it's like this stuff you
don't know what to do you just gotta do
you receive that you next every day
detector pain in your chance nobody has
the plan continues with the gambling but
what you see is what you get them yeah
what you see is what you get so you can
always expect everything to go your way
keep on grinding for you gonna see your
day but ever one of the things I've got
most of these here I'm just extremely
impressed and grateful for the hustle
that this office is up executing up
we're working on that book there's a lot
of scenarios there that played out
really separate for like two rulers will
just one min base variable but I'm I'm
just I'm hearing community attitude and
energy of the office I just appreciate
the uh I just really appreciate gracious
tutorial the words thank you
you mean being pressing I'm around we
may be tracked at me run it back expect
if I can get back to the time we had no
worry dating was okay claim with a
little late deployed came through and it
like
right today but what you see is what you
get though yep what you see is what you
so now that we support a wall and you
have a blonde in a macula of wine back
to doing the live blogging system makes
a man just stop me are you
yes oh my god good how are you good to
see you young man just stop me I told
you go like no use them wine before that
what do you want me to get back up I
think I'm of the other person and
there's and then George yes if you like
go through a tintype you know you know
I'm a demon I go through ups and downs
like in two thousand items unloader like
there's no I appreciate I appreciate
appreciate its offensive numbers
grateful government business so worried
what are you tell me I want to hear like
what is one of those beautiful piece of
content to get the most out three areas
of normal racial govern Advocacy Center
or the public side
Kim skinny one of tho I really like to
wait Pacifica networks articles like jab
jab jab like that but it's like the more
granular yeah even the other databases
have self person or thing first thing
you'll like it
while I'm calibrating one of the things
that I really focus on is I don't want
to talk until I'm a hundred percent
positive which is why I have such
conviction when I talk in Alexa voice in
modern Facebook video some deeper
influencing marketing stuff I'm like
this close and while I'm doing it I'm in
the other part of me which I'm excited
optimistic called motivational I'm
empathetic that it takes a piece of the
audience thing up he's getting two
robots or two nothing and that's on the
tail what I think that audience you your
friends that are talking about it are
going to really appreciate is when I'm
done cross my T's and dotting my eyes on
this next level and stuff all those were
a year or two or eighteen months or nine
months of more detail in it and even a
moment like this pushes means more
towards getting closer to baby okay I'll
look at it okay thanks for that to be
better oh yeah I wish you well you saw
he's leading critical feedback he's like
hey you're getting a little too rah-rah
I like back to details that Jab Jab that
leave I just saw it I don't explain it
and now that is the piece of content
right like that's the piece of content
there's an interesting insight that's a
piece of talk that I can talk about now
to you as I'm breaking this wall about
like wow you never know what's going to
happen that's going to lead to the thing
and now you get to watch it and see like
oh the thing can happen out of nowhere
that's the puzzle
he's on a map even though some people
said it was all black kind of baby
please don't time to be great so we may
distract them before they're back back
back to the line can you back to the
time we had don't worry chanting was
okay name was a gentle wave deploy came
through natalenko click to run today
[Music]